r walk n
general character pack
rene r ender ender ender eagnas ah leg
drug de ga goron
refer to do ya do do the gold digger su
I was very worried before you did it, but what should I do if no one really comes?
I was just worried, but since the
first day, a lot of users have been supporting me,
so I'm really happy now. I'm glad I did it.
4 slot genei I'm going to save you
ah ah ah ah
We are planning to make it available to
retailers as well related to do ary exr style de bonheur
They
said that it would be quite difficult to find a way to raise awareness of
it, so if that's the case, how much is the software called Nikon 1
needed by all users?  At the same time, I thought that I should promote the name like this
, which is
the reason why I started doing
Kickstarter.  It's a very
happy future, but
if things don't go well,
it'll just be left over from that huge risk.
A house Ah
doodle It's
under development, but we've been working hard for 6 months and it's going smoothly It's just a game that tells us what the status of the game is
and friendship is square
enix That's been advertised, so there's nothing we can comment on right now
ad bt e 4 fc 2 gay r performance
socho shopping
ah
no,
there were some hard times, but the hardest thing was
the title I made over 7 years ago, so
now we have the version of the engine  because it's completely different
The most difficult task was to bring all these
things together, but it wasn't so much that the herbs were to blame for each
piece of hardware.
If you say that there are two screens, and if you're going to port from there,
well, porting it to the hardware is a little like this, too.
I had to
pay very close attention to that point that I
had to realize.
It's been ported without any damage
, and even with two screens, it's perfectly appropriate to have the two screens on
one screen, so you can
change the size and position of the screens in a natural way.
When you have to look at the sub-paper, it will be automatically published when it is published, and it
will disappear when it is no longer needed, so it is very
easy to play.  Of course, the stable frame rate is a
benefit because the wave performance has improved, but what we focused on was
the game design part of the game, and the
original is good.  Sometimes we couldn't make the transition
, such as making it more user-friendly, making it easier to play, or adjusting the difficulty level.
I think
the flame of voodoo n well
you do your That's right, right?
In that sense, from
that pt full field to this remastered Banwa this time
, the image is that there are three types of colors that each hero has, a hero that transforms alone and a group squadron.
But the other thing is that giant hero.  It's called
Logy, so it doesn't mean that the game system of the characters, which is the world view of the character,
has something in common with the three, but
this time, it's really independent
and has a very unique game system.  I want to make it into a work, so I want you to look
forward to it
.
It's really recently,
well, I've always wanted to have an IP of my own with Platinum,
ever since the company was founded, but at that point it wasn't like I wanted to create a separate power source.
Well, all sorts of preparations had been made, so
there was a competition in the car where there were eight people, and everyone submitted proposals for the games they wanted to make,
and packed them up.
I didn't apply for the competition because I wanted to leave it up to the dispatch of the new staff,
but at that time, even within myself, I wanted to make a game like this, so
I told Inaba about it.
We thought it was interesting, so we made proposals for each computer, and we thought that this was the most interesting, so
if it was a one-on-one jersey company, we decided to make this
project.
Masu voodoo ad 4 a
When I launched that project as a web data kudu producer, the original play of this game's fun vortex dual
action was from the initial planning stage, so I definitely wanted to make this, so
I worked hard.  Do you think the start-up run will
take the form of
a rastar eafe voodoo voodoo supervisor?
It was a
very unique game called
Tsunade, and everything was a new challenge.
By the way, there were a lot of good ideas, but it
wasn't quite organized, so I went in
and said that it was probably the correct choice based on my own experience.
alea alea
per maresall distribution a form the birth day
use me to do Ah,
the Bayonetta that I was involved with is the version, isn't it?
Come on, I ca
n't do it, so I
'm going to fall into those two types
.  It's
a company that I started with the idea of doing something, so it's very regret
able that I'm interested in the effects of the titles that will be created in the future.
I think that's the kind of company that's like that love or interest is like that
voodoo d 4 s 4 xlr hoodie re 6 f
n me
[music]